the thing that is most
alarming in one sense is that the woman
who was the director of The Truth and
Reconciliation committee which was set
up to investigate these claims has said
that this should be treated as denialism
and it should be made subject to
criminal and civil sanctions so if you
say I don't believe these stories or if
you say there's no evidence that this is
true or if you say the evidence is that
most of these claims are provably false
then she wants you to be prosecuted and
the Canadian Justice Minister has said
okay politicians say all sorts of things
we know but he said he's open to this
idea so what what you actually have had
is is the Justice minister of Canada
saying that he's open to the idea of
Prosecuting people who are trying to
defend Canada against charges of
genocide